[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John will answer your
questions we'll give you a dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon how are
you doing John I'm doing great
everything is beautiful here there is
one issue Hank that's a that's been
hanging over I think all of our heads
since last week which is that careful
listeners of the podcast may have
noticed that in our last episode I I
said that we'd received like 478
Snickers bars at the office and then
later in the episode I said like 458 and
then later in the episode I said like
437 at one point you said a number that
I had said previously and then I
corrected you that sounds about right I
have the final number here the actual
number did you go and count all your
Snickers bars I counted them one by one
because they came and you know a certain
number of boxes but I emptied out all
the boxes just just so that I could put
them in my bathtub so that I could have
a Snickers bath and are you gonna tell
me the number of Snickers that are
currently left or the number you
received the number I received was 384
so a lot of holidays to everyone for
getting that number so terribly wrong
but most of all to my sponsor my
longtime corporate sponsor
Snickers maker of the most delicious
snack on earth so currently I have about
mmm on say like 200 odd Snickers
remaining I I think that it would be
great if we could if we get to sort of
follow you around in your personal life
and and take every moment where you
exaggerate unlike an objective
exaggeration it's like an actual number
and figure out what the percentage is
like averaged out what the percentage is
that you exaggerate by super-interesting
I'd be they'd be interesting to find out
if it was like a if it was consistent
like this is how much Jon exaggerate so
we can sort of say it objectively or it
just flies all around
I think it's exactly I think it's almost
exactly 384 458 is how much I exaggerate
I would be interested to know how many
Snickers bars are actually left because
you did just exaggerate how many
Snickers bars you've eaten I hope I mean
you know I'd slightly exaggerated it
maybe but I haven't been enjoying at
least I would say a handful of Snickers
bars per day they are delicious
can I tell you a story John please so we
recently moved to a different office and
in the process of moving you know we
just sort of like grabbed stuff as it
was and put it on a truck and one of the
things we grabbed was this trunk that
opens up you guys think we got it at
Target and they decide there's like some
storage space I was going through the
office to be like oh yeah at all this
stuff to like figure out where things
were and I opened it that trunk and
inside there was a bag of Halloween
candy an open bag of Halloween candy
with some three musketeers and Snickers
and starbursts in it and I was very
pleased and excited to find this and I
started and I just like took a handful
and closed it up
and then and I kept doing that for weeks
and it was just like a wonderful little
treat that I had but oh but as time went
on people saw me doing it and they were
like what is there are there treats are
there treats in that trunk and and so
this bag of Halloween candy that had
been totally undiscovered since last
Halloween so almost a year now I I was
it was like my secret for about a week
before before the the knowledge of the
location of the treats exponentially
grew throughout the office until now of
course there are only starbursts left
that reminds me that after the coming
nuclear apocalypse we may be low on food
but there will always be starbursts is
that the short poem for today that's
that's our short poem there will always
be starbursts
yeah let's skip the short poem today and
instead focus just a little bit more
attention on whether or not we can get a
corporate sponsor to send us 384 more
Snickers bars because I am concerned
about
what I'm gonna do when these Snickers
run out I just want to point out that
you got Snickers bars and our office
didn't and now my office knows about
that my office ba one that actually sold
the sponsorship at VidCon they're like
why didn't we get a but and we have a
whole thing about MMS which is also a
Mars brand and and it's there's a great
deal of contention now about the fact
that we do not we did not get our
favorite candy and you did I think I
think what concerns me about the way
that you're constructing this Snickers
issue is that you are imagining that my
office received 384 Snickers bars and
I'm absolutely clear about something for
the sake of my own health and for the
sake of the health of my employees for
the for the vibe in this office those
384 Snickers bars were addressed to me
they are my Snickers bars a portion of
them may reside in the office
refrigerator but they are mine they
belong to me they will be consumed
solely by myself I that is that is
remarkable to me I I are you sure that
that's that that's the the best thing
for for your employees to be like hey I
got a bunch of stuff I'm your boss I'm
gonna keep it I don't think they really
think of me as their boss I think they
think of me as like the strange man who
shows up some days John can I can I do
it can I perform a short poem for this
podcast absolutely
the the poem for this podcast is from
the just the notes that is at the top of
our podcast notes document and those
notes are 384 Snickers helium car would
be slightly lighter than air car The
Fault in Our Stars is not available on
Netflix that's a short poem we is
generally called 384 Snickers it's by
John Green and from the podcast notes of
our August 1st 2016 episode oh boy it's
not August 1st when this goes
when this is aired but it is true that a
car with helium tires would it turns out
be slightly lighter than a car with air
tires about 0.25 pounds lighter nicholas
did the math and boy did he do the math
we will put the math on our patreon page
at patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
and now Hank it is time very belatedly
to get to some questions from our
listeners alright this one is from Trey
who asks dear Hank and John in recent
weeks both stranger things and the new
Harry Potter play came out I want to
tweet about those things but I don't
want to spoil things for others but one
of my favorite parts of Twitter is
sharing experiences with people at what
point can I post without a guilty
conscience I have no idea how to handle
this Hank is it never is the answer
never it's never I still do not post
Harry Potter
spoilers like I do not tweet about like
what is like there will always be
someone reading Harry Potter for the
first time and not like wow like if you
want to have a conversation if you want
to like have it have a conversation
about Harry Potter be like hey can
anybody come join me in this chatroom
who's already read cursed child can I
can you please like let's create a space
where where people who have enjoyed
stranger things and want to discuss it
can we go to a place that is that is not
about as segmented off from the rest of
the Internet
the idea that all that all you know
discussion on the Internet has to happen
in this like uber public forum of either
Twitter or YouTube or you know like
that's like that's not how it has to be
we can create social spaces on the
internet that are not not in the faces
of a hundred percent of the people who
follow you I'm not totally convinced of
that like because I don't know exactly
where the line is like if I tweet about
the results of the most recent AFC
Wimbledon game have I spoiled the
experience that AFC Wimbledon game for
people who wanted to like wait to watch
the highlights on now
I'm item I might be biased here but I
feel like real life things mm-hmm are
different from fictional things so it's
not like like okay if I if I don't know
who won the Canadian election
like Prime Minister Justin Trudeau is
and I'm like ah dang it you spoiled it
for me just the world that's life that
like I was gonna watch the election
coverage later that's the thing that
happened in the real world okay so the
rule is that you can never spoil
fictions on broadly available public
social media however you can spoil
nonfiction zhh yes because cuz I mean I
think that can you spoil the nonfiction
book are you allowed to spoil a memoir
yes because it's it's true facts of
things that happened and I think that we
do that all the time it's like when
someone publishes a memoir
oftentimes what will happen is the news
story will be like this book came out
and this person said these five things
because then it's a news I actually a
story that it's funny you should say
that Hank because I felt like the movie
Titanic was a little bit spoiled for me
just because I happen to already know in
advance what happens you know like with
the Titanic I knew that it was gonna
sink yeah and I felt like if I could
have gone at that experience cold it
would have been a much more powerful
film for me because I would have been
like oh my oh my oh my goodness
I thought this was just gonna be a cute
love story yeah but no it turns out that
this is terrible and for some reason
Kate Winslet is not willing to share her
door and now Leonardo DiCaprio is gonna
die oh dang it I get it I spoil the
movie I apologize I'm very sorry that si
si Leonardo DiCaprio's character in
Titanic didn't actually exist that
portion was fictional and so you can't
spoil it you can however say that the
Titanic sank because that is a thing
that happened all right so there
apparently is the line and I have
crossed it for which I apologize Hank we
also have a question from Sarah and this
question is as follows Dear John and
Hank I started playing Pokemon go almost
as soon as it was released back when the
servers were super flaky and even though
the game seems to be working fine now I
have a serious problem you see I live in
a rural area and there are no pokemons
or pokey stops that can be easily
accessed from my home I also can't drive
yet and because of my parents busy
schedule
they can't just drive me places simply
for the sake
okay Mona what do I do well Sarah I
think that you first of all need to
twist your parents arms and tell them to
drive you places also just get an
apartment downtown I'm imagining you're
13 or 14 years old just get that up just
do it get a job drop out of school
you'll be fine you got to focus on
getting up to love life no you won't
that's terrible terrible terrible advice
listen I like catching pokémon as next
as much as the next person or possibly
more given that I have just reached
level 21 however I really feel strongly
that you need to wait Sarah for better
augmented reality games to come out that
are friendlier to people living in rural
spaces and then just take your take your
moments when they come you know your
school will almost definitely be a poky
stop so when school starts back up you
know you can you can stop paying
attention in class and just you know
make sure that you update that get your
pokéballs from the pokey stop every six
minutes and our advice on this topic is
terrible Hank we're all headed and we're
just both headed in terrible directions
I think here's here's my here's here's
my proposal John we create a new game
it's called nama kapag and it's it's
just like Pokemon go accept all the
places where there are Pokemon there
aren't any and then all the places where
there aren't Pokemon there are tons yeah
it'll get all the city dwellers out into
the country land and all the and all the
rural people can be like ha ha ha I got
like a level 84 Narvel black and
everybody would be like what is that
even I've never even heard of that nama
cop so that's a pretty penny proposal I
like that idea a lot
we should talk to Niantic about this
exciting opportunity where they don't
even have to license the Pokemon
characters they just spell them
backwards and put them make them
slightly less cute and suddenly it's not
even a problem all right I got I got
another question John if you would like
to hear this question yes I would it's
from Katie who asks dear Hank and John
I'm about two months away from moving
into college I'm going to be living in a
triple room me and two roommates
in a room that was built for two people
the layout of this room is one loft bed
with a desk and a wardrobe built into it
and then the other two beds as bunk beds
I want the loft bed because it's the
best bed and so does everybody else is
there a way for me to get my preferred
and everyone else has preferred bed
without seeming like a total jerk I mean
in this situation
I take the worst bed ten times out of
ten - yeah get myself in good with my
new roommates I was gonna so there I
feel like there are a ton of different
answers to this question based on like
economic theories like if you if you if
it's like the Communists theory or like
then then you all have to just like
switch beds every night if it's like the
sort of emeriti idea of of like helping
like you know like incremental taxation
and progressive taxation then you would
say like okay who's the wealthiest
person in the room they get the worst
bed if it's a you know if it's just like
American egalitarianism then you have to
just be like Rochambeau and then you
pick or you know you have the person pay
for the best bed you pay the other
roommates you say hey I want the best
bed here's 50 bucks and then the other
ones are like well I'll give you fifty
two for it haha and then it's just it's
just capital yeah so that but I do like
John suggestion which is which is more
sort of communitarian like just say hey
I'm gonna sacrifice a thing for you and
and we're gonna be friends because of it
I think that what you want
at college ultimately is not a slightly
better bed but better relationships like
you have to get along so well with
people for those like triple rooms to
work at all that I just feel like it's a
very marginal gain for real risk like as
you know Hank I'm a very risk-averse
person but I feel like the downside is
significant and the upside probably
isn't as significant as you think right
yeah I think about this all the time
like like our per seat like the
differences between the perceived levels
of goodness of a product and but once
you actually have it in are using it
you're like well yeah I mean it's it's
just yet
it's the the thing that I thought was
gonna make me happy made me happy maybe
in the moment but not for like actually
in the long term not really and and I've
I I particularly think about this when
I'm watching house hunters and the
people are always choose the larger
house that's farther from work and I'm
like you are choosing to spend so much
time in traffic in exchange for the
thing that has been objectively proven
scientifically to not make you happier
whereas spending time in traffic but
when you're looking the problem is when
you're looking for a house you can't
help but think about the house like
you're making that decision inside the
Hat inside alarm on the way back when
Sarah and I were looking at houses when
we were moving to Indianapolis and we
were looking at houses for the first
time at no point did we any of the
things that we consider actually affect
our quality of life whereas a bunch of
things that didn't factor into our
consideration at all were extremely
important like looking back the number
one thing that I wish I'd looked for in
a house was a house that did not have
much lawn and it didn't even cross my
mind I was like Oh mowing the lawn is
fun it turns out that is nothing else
and are there are there any other house
hunting tips John that you have for us I
mean I guess like the number one house
hunting tip that I would make is never
make a decision while you're hungry
that's just a tip in general though like
I find that better decisions when you're
not hungry
and also have found in my own life that
one of the best ways to not be hungry is
to eat Snickers bars is yeah I thought
maybe we were working towards a Snickers
integration Joe hashtag sponsored all
right Hank we have another question this
one comes from Ella who writes Dear John
and Hank I've recently started
volunteering at my local charity book
shop and have been given free rein over
organizing the many many shelves Ella
congratulations on the greatest and also
most exciting responsibility that you
will probably ever have in your life how
do I organize them like fiction and
crime and thriller are obviously
organized by author but what about
sections like mental health and
self-help or crap
Durex or any of the many categories that
aren't fiction in crime do I organize by
subcategory stress death sex
relationships or do I stick to going by
author or do I go for the aesthetic
version and go by height what should I
do
Ella this is a wonderful question this
is one of the great questions of being a
human alive in the world today how do I
organize my books or if I am very lucky
how do I organize someone else's books I
think this is I mean literally there are
entire like like not just courses but
entire programs that people go through
in school in this particular topic and
lots of them will probably be listening
to the podcast right now and so I really
don't want to say anything as I'm afraid
I will offend them use the Dewey Decimal
t' I mean I would I believe in going
with the Library of Congress cataloging
system the Dewey Decimal System is also
excellent but I love the Library of
Congress cataloging system I just think
that it's very you can google it it's I
just find it to be pretty comprehensive
but one of the fascinating things about
cataloging a library whether it's your
home library or a book shop or a public
library is that there are all these
books that live in the in-between spaces
that defy easy categorization like in my
own home library I have a section for
books about conjoined twins Hank because
as you know I have a lot of books about
conjoined twins but there are some books
that are about more than one thing right
like there are some books I have for
instance a book that is about both
boxing and the Holocaust
now does that go in boxing or does it go
in Holocaust studies this these are like
these turn out to be kind of like really
interesting deep questions and that's
one of the reasons I love cataloging and
re cataloging my home library is that in
addition to like always reminding me of
books that I want to reread or that I
never haven't gotten to read it also
like always reminds me that you know the
world even though we have to organize it
is always like resisting our our
organizational impulses mm-hmm yes that
the world does not want to be
catalogued it does not not want to be
simple it does not want to be yeah yep
but but we must for the sake of we must
find the most it is our obligation to
ourselves into each other to find ways
to catalog the uncharacterized vault so
just do it by color and and and you know
do JA do not do it by color and be
really good I was actually just look at
my bookshelf and I said that and like I
have all the Scot pilgrims one two three
four five six and they're all different
colors and it'd be like oh great so it's
like my Scott my like my sick Scott
Scott pilgrims are in different spots in
my libraries yeah all across my house
depending on like which was the three
the blue one or was the orange one yeah
so L we're gonna encourage you to
consult with a local librarian because
they know a lot more about that stuff
than we do and also because librarians
are the best all right John I got
another question it's from Tom who asks
dear Hank and John I've just finished a
couple of years of cancer treatment and
I possibly foolishly started running the
numbers the NHS has spent somewhere in
excess of 2.5 million pounds to extend
my life by probably as little as a
couple of years how could I possibly
repay that debt to society in such a
short space of time how can I justify
that my life is worth that much when
that money could have saved millions if
it had been spent more wisely we very
rarely rationally allocate resources so
the idea that you should feel
responsible for irrational allocation of
resources is is a bit of a stretch I
think because the world doesn't allocate
resources rationally
that's the first thing that I would say
the second thing that I would say is
that you have to remember that life
doesn't exist for for money money exists
for life and the third thing that I
would say is that the NHS and every
human being that comes after you has
also benefited from your treatment
because you have contributed to their
understanding of cancer you've
contributed to their understanding of
how to treat it and that's a really
important contribution to the history of
the the social order right
that's the main way that we've learned
is by trying to treat people figuring
out what works and what doesn't work so
you can't separate the money that's been
spent on you from the the good it's done
not just for you and those who love you
but also for the wider social yeah and
and in that same vein with regard to the
social order the NHS and healthcare
systems in general exist not just so
that we can take care of the people who
are sick but for the people who are
healthy to know that they can be taken
care of and will be taken care of when
and if they get sick and that creates a
feeling of security and it creates a
feeling of value of being valued by your
society and by your government to know
that that system is there and and that
in that cost that you have just applied
just to you as actually kind of
providing a benefit across all people in
your country who can feel as if like
they know that you know that that that
money would have been spent on them if
they had been at a enough to be in your
situation and so that that cost
basically gets spread out over all of
those people who get to have that
sensation of safety and of support and
of being valued by their society yeah I
think survivor's guilt is so difficult
and it's very very real and this is one
expression of it among many and I'm not
going to pretend to be able to take that
feeling away or that fear away but I
think ultimately the the value of any
human life if you try to calculate it
monetarily everything falls apart yes I
just don't think I just don't think that
human lives are if that like the value
or worth of a human life can effectively
be measured by markets no no though I I
think that I think that sometimes we try
and it's very upsetting yeah I mean -
yeah all right John I have another
question if you want to go a little bit
lighter than that one it's from Kelly
who asks dear Hank and John when there's
a large-scale tug-of-war happening I've
seen a lot of people using the
two three pull method instead of having
all the members of their team constantly
pulling well I've seen this work and
agree that it's the most effective
effective way to win tug-of-war
I don't understand why it works in my
head I would think that if the other
team was constantly pulling with all
their collective might that they would
win during the break while my team is
counting to three so why does my team
win well it might just be that your team
is strong and burly and amazing and
great and just excellent tug-of-war
people with with really nice calves but
but but I have I have some thoughts John
do you have any uh well I'm not very
good at math but my general thought
would be that by saying one two three
pull while another team is applying
constant pressure you would apply a
sudden surge of pressure that they would
not be like prepared for mentally that
might cause them to like stumble and
fall over yeah I think there's a couple
of things at work here first is that no
one is ever pulling with all of their
like no one is ever pulling with all of
their might together on like the the
constant pull is actually very hard to
maintain so you're you're not giving a
hundred percent all at once and so
you're sort of like always counting on
someone being pulling harder than you
are and then sometimes you're pulling
harder and sometimes they're pulling
harder so everyone is no one is actually
pulling constantly everyone is pulling
like at varying speeds and then it
averages out over the side that's that's
supposedly pulling with all of their
collective might and then that's also
happening on the other side people are
all pulling a little bit like a fair
amount to keep to keep themselves from
being pulled over but then they all do
that sudden surge at the same time
instead of having that averaged out over
the whole rope
it happens all at once and so there's
that so there's a greater force being
generated then we'll ever be generated
by the other side and then the other
thing is to just keep keep them off
balance because tug-of-war is is a game
of strength but it is also a game of
agility and balance and keeping your
footing not sliding forward and not
being like not having your your center
of gravity go too low that you lose
traction and not having it go too high
so that you stumble over your feet so
that is that is what I would guess
and I probably took that question
probably took it too serious yeah I mean
as you can tell Hank fancies himself an
expert in the field of tug-of-war even
though I I would I would wager that the
last time I competed in a competitive
tug-of-war match was mmm 20 years ago 25
maybe I'd say maybe 19 I bet I don't
care before at summer camp but I do ride
the the I I think you might falsely
remember how long ago summer camp was
definitely way how old am i I was in
summer camp nineteen years ago were you
yeah I'm 36 so you were in summer camp
when you were 17 yeah I went I was eight
I was a junior counselor John oh all
right I just guess I don't remember that
one more comment about the one two three
pull business it occurs to me that since
tug-of-war is ultimately a game about
balance you should really say one pull
all all your opponents are getting ready
for that pole but if you just say one
pull like they're not gonna be ready at
all that is I think I might have just I
think I might have just cracked the code
right to being successful at tug-of-war
hang no what do you really need to do is
you need to have a system down before
you go in and you're like okay we're
gonna pull on through the first pole
we're gonna pull on two second pull pull
on five third pull pull on three fourth
pull pull on one and then everybody will
be so confused but everybody on your
team knows exactly what's happening I
love it I think that's actually I think
that's actually exactly how NFL teams
call plays like that's how quarterbacks
do it in the huddle although at this
point we're veering into something that
we truly know nothing about which is
playing American football so perhaps we
should answer one more question from our
listeners before we get to the
all-important news from Mars so I have I
have a thing that I want to bring up
John okay is that okay gotta bring up a
thick I'd guess is that I am very
interested in the moment when a sport
goes from pure fun to like super
competitive and for me that moment is
when someone introduces a strategy that
makes them much better at this
worked that then everyone else has to
emulate but it requires some significant
investment of either time or money and
then everybody is like oh like the
people who are who are like this is this
was fun
but I'm not here for that they all drop
out and then suddenly Ultimate Frisbee
becomes this thing that I can no longer
play because there are rules and
penalties and you can't drink a beer
while you're doing it yeah I mean I
guess the only counter-argument would be
that there are lots of sports that you
can drink a beer while doing that are
still super competitive and in fact are
possibly made more competitive by the
presence of beer I'm thinking especially
of the adult softball league that I was
briefly a part of which involved a lot
of drinking and then also a lot of
screaming at an umpire and I would just
be like but-but-but we're not playing
for anything there's no money there's no
pride here we're all old people why are
you yelling that you were safe at second
like let it go I think some of the
competitive energy just comes from human
nature yeah I think that's definitely
true all right but now can we answer one
more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon yes we can now I think this
question comes from Robert who asks Dear
John and Hank in episode 12 of dear Hank
and John dang it I said dear Hank and
John in episode 12 of Dear John and Hank
you discussed the multiverse theory and
you said that in only two of the 14
quadrillion possibilities does Donald
Trump become the Republican nominee for
president Oh of all the dubious stuff
we've ever said that might have been the
most dubious you said he won't actually
win the presidency in either of these
universes but did say that in one of
them an asteroid will hit the earth and
kill all but seventeen Americans I
haven't slept since the Donald
officially accepted the nomination I
just sit quietly in bed weep and try not
to wake my husband what should I do
uh so I'm confused if this person is
tremendously overwhelmed by the
possibility that we are now in a 50/50
scenario with the asteroid impact or if
it's just Donald Trump that's that's
upsetting them I mean given that there's
a 50/50 chance that all but seventeen
Americans will die in the next couple of
months due to an ass
I really feel like I need to be eating
more Snickers per day yeah we've got
we've gone down to the only two
possibilities and we're not sure which
one we're in so yeah yeah I've got it
I've got to increase my SPD ratio yeah
we know you start living every day like
it's our last because because for for
all but 17 of us that's the case 50/50
chance 250g ah the world is not going to
I mean the world is going to end it's
going to be terrible but it's not going
to happen soon I don't think it's
unlikely to happen soon I'm really
hedging my bets here Robert the world is
unlikely to end soon the multiverse
turns out to be a far more complex and
terrifying place than any of us could
have anticipated back in episode 12 but
I still I still believe that that the
United States is a strong country and a
good place to live and a very successful
nation-state in many ways and it's
important to remember that even in
extremely difficult strange worry
sometimes that you know I remember John
McCain caught a lot of flack in 2008
amid the collapse of the economy for
saying the fundamentals of our economy
are strong but he was right the
fundamentals of our economy are strong
in the sense that you know people people
like the currency of the dollar they
value it you know the our crime rate
remains relatively low compared to the
1990s the 1980s you know that there are
a lot of things about the United States
that are good it's very easy to focus on
the things that are terrifying the only
other thing that I would say is vote yes
yes which brings me to the the
sponsorships for this episode of dear
Hank and John which is brought to you by
the fundamentals of our economy the
fundamentals of the American economy
John according to John McCain and also
reality they are strong ish I mean not
that strong but strong ish and of course
that is episode
dear Hank and John is also brought to
you by Leonardo DiCaprio Leonardo
DiCaprio still feeling like there was
probably room on that door for him his
father guest is additionally brought to
you by nama kapag nama kapa the new the
new hit game from the antic which allows
you to play Pokemon type game without
having to license any of the Pokemon
names and also while you do not happen
to live in a city and finally today's
podcast is brought to you by the Library
of Congress cataloging system the
Library of Congress cataloging system
may be the best
maybe not we're not sure they're just
the ones who paid us to say that we like
I've got I've got two corporate
relationships saying I've got one with
the Library of Congress cataloging
system and I got one with Snickers Oh
God
alright this has been a fun episode of
dear Hank and John John I know but now
we have to get to the the part where you
tell me that human beings are
desperately trying to get to a cold dead
Rock when they have a lovely home right
here on earth is very nice here at Earth
John I have to say though though I will
also say that yesterday in Montana
there was a high of 35 Earth a high of
95 and a low of 35 which seemed a little
bit excessive to me
additionally the fire season has begun
and there are some really quite nearby
raging fires that have created a lot of
of air quality problems but it is that
is terrible it is really Hank are their
fires on Mars there are no fires on Mars
yeah it is a fire free place yeah why is
that so that's good because there's no
life so there's no air so yeah no oxygen
and no combustible material so it sounds
like l.x I guess not hell because
there's no fire but yeah so what's the
news from Mars well the news is from the
National Geographic Channel who is
working out of what it looks to be a
very interesting series that I am NOT a
hundred percent sure I will enjoy but
I'm hoping that I will and I'm really
excited to to see whether or not I'm
going to like it it's called Mars
and it is a it's a global event series
coming this November that's what it says
global event series I think what they
mean is show TV show which is a drama
but it sort of mixed together with the
realities of exploring Mars so it's a
drama a six-part series scripted drama
in which some people go to Mars and it
looks I'd watch the trailer for it which
you can watch at make Mars home calm
which is the website for this thing that
looks really quite exciting and they'll
be mixing together the scripted drama
with like actual people who are like
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Elon Musk and
Peter Diamandis and people like that who
will also be talking about the mission
and yeah it's being excited produced by
Ron Howard and and and Brian Grazer and
I think it looks like a it looks like a
fun cool show that will be celebrating
the spirit of adventure the spirit of
exploration and and all of the all of
the stuff that goes along with it and
all the drama and freakiness and and
scary but there won't be but it will be
I think hard science fiction no no
aliens and stuff just a story of the
first humans to explore the surface of
Mars a question for you where is it
being filmed do you know Mars John it's
being told I'm in big trouble that means
I already lost my bet no it's being so
here's the question John could we make
the argument that humans go to Mars but
in like virtual reality television shows
no I don't think we can make that
argument all right I think that my bet
is looking better and better with each
passing day well Hank it is still the
offseason for AFC Wimbledon but not for
much longer
their first game is next week
very exciting up there in the third tier
of English football we're gonna get a
nosebleed we're sitting up so high we're
actually going to start the year Hank
because AFC Wimbledon is first in the
alphabet at the
top of the league one table oh right see
where we go from there
the news from fancy Wimbledon this week
is that after quite a long time of not
signing a striker to replace auto bio
Aachen phenoix AFC Wimbledon finally
have his name is Tyrone Barnett possibly
Barnett I'm not good at pronouncing
things and he is 30 years old he is Hank
get this from Stevenage oh you stole my
best player no no he grew up in
Stevenage but he never played for
Stevenage no worries
he played for Shrewsbury Town and South
and United and is now coming to
Wimbledon I have to say at Southend
United he had five goals in 20
appearances and that's a pretty good
that's a pretty good ratio so I'm
feeling hopeful and excited about our
new 30 year old striker welcome to
Wimbledon Tyrone Barnet or possibly
Barnet long may you reign long may you
reign
well congratulations John so nervous
about this season Hank I know well is
there a way to print out the table as it
stands at the beginning of the season
and just frame it
do they have it's all downhill from here
they have like a thing that you could
route like that they actually release
like a physical copy that you could get
I don't know I don't know that's a good
question I'll have to ask Hank what did
we learn today Oh John we learned that
if you want to win at at at tug-of-war
all you need to do is listen to me
because I am an expert on everything to
do with tug-of-war apparently because I
just thought about it for a little bit
yeah that reminds me of how we're
experts in everything because we just
thought about it for a little bit while
we were recording a podcast together we
also learned that the opportunity to
catalog the shelves at a bookshop is the
greatest opportunity on earth and we
learned that you should not be sharing
spoilers of any fictional things on the
internet but if you want to tell the
whole world that Justin Trudeau is the
Prime Minister of Canada that is
acceptable and of course we learned
that soon you will be able to download a
game called nama cop aaaghh that will
allow you to play a Pokemon go like game
but in rural spaces very excited for
nama cop bog I think it has a great
future Hank one quick suggestion maybe
if you could make the name not so
terrible it occurs to me that there's
probably be awed nama cop because that
would be the reverse of the whole thing
aughh nama cop is much better it does
fortunate Leo arrived there at the very
end of the podcast thank you for
listening Hank thank you for doing this
podcast with me the podcasts edited by
Nicholas Jenkins our theme music is by
gunnarolla our intern is claudia morales
rosianna halse rojas helps out with
questions you can email us at Hank and
Jonna gmail.com and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]